[MUSIC]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Payments Live.
And Happy New Year 2013.
PENG YING: Happy New Year's.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes, it is our
first show this year.
And we'll have a lightweight
office hour style session.
We'll answer questions from
Stack Overflow, the groups,
and the moderator.
So first, let's start with
a few announcements.
We just launched a new digital
subscription course on Google
Developers Academy.
You can find it if you go to
developers.google.com/academy
or from our main Google Commerce
landing page if you
follow the training link.
You can find that at
developers.google.com/commerce.
PENG YING: And a second
announcement, for those of you
who follow the Google Commerce
blog you're probably already
aware of it, but for those
tuning in, we recently
announced Zavers, which is a
digital coupon solution for
loyalty cards.
And you can find out more
about it at zavers.com.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool,
more savings.
PENG YING: Everybody
loves savings.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right, let's
go to the questions.
Let's see what we have here.
PENG YING: I guess I'll start.
MIHAI IONESCU: You want
to take the first one.
PENG YING: Yeah, so the new
version of Google Wallet has
been looming for months,
where is it?
And what changes
will it bring?
I know we've been saying
that we can't
wait for it to launch.
And that it's going
to be awesome.
Unfortunately, it's been delayed
for a little bit.
And then, we can't really tell
you when it will launch.
All we can say is that
it's coming.
So in the future when it
launches, we'll definitely
give you a heads up.
And we will tell you about the
APIs that it brings and the
benefits it can bring both
merchants and consumers.
But for now, it's just going to
be a little bit of a wait.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, we have
quite a few exciting APIs, so
it's worth the wait.
So next question is
about Zavers.
We were just talking about it.
The question is, is Zavers
integrated with Google Wallet
somehow and it's not exposed
to users yet?
If not, when will the
users see it?
Will the integration be
different for retailers versus
manufacturers?
So as a consumer, as a user,
you can already use Zavers.
If you go to zavers.com
you can sign up
on the online site.
And you will see a list of
available retailers where you
can redeem the coupons.
On the mobile side, if you have
a smartphone or a Google
Wallet app, you can
navigate there.
It's a mobile web app and you
can use it in the store the
same way as you'd use
the online site
to redeem the coupons.
So the coupon would be
saved to your app.
And then when you swipe your
loyalty card it'll be
automatically redeemed.
PENG YING: Cool.
I guess I'll take
the next one.
So can I add cards from
authorized users that are not
main cards on the account?
So there's a few different
ways to take it.
One of them is as a
consumer and the
other one is as a merchant.
Well, I guess there's two
different ways to take it.
As a merchant, if you want to
charge something on your
customer's behalf, that
currently isn't allowed by the
checkout terms of service.
So the example here is that if
one of your customers calls in
and says, I'd like to place an
order, and passes you their
credit card information, you
can't then enter their credit
card information into the
account to complete that
transaction and use
Google Checkout as
your payment gateway.
From the consumer side, let's
say that you're buying
something for your mom.
And she hands you her
credit card number.
Because you're buying her
something on her behalf, and
she has your permission, and
you're a consumer, you can
enter in her credit card number
into your account and
then purchase that way.
But that's only if she gives
you permission, of course.
MIHAI IONESCU: Right, and you
would need all the information
anyway, like billing
address, zip code--
PENG YING: Exactly, you would
have to have all the
information--
MIHAI IONESCU: Only the owner
should have access to all that
information.
PENG YING: Ideally, only the
owner should be the person
that's entering the credit
card information.
But sometimes it's
understandable that you have
to make purchases on other
people's behalfs.
And, I think, in those cases as
long as you have permission
to, as a consumer, that's OK.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
I'll take the next one.
This is a Google Checkout
question.
The question is, when I'm trying
to add a Checkout Buy
Now button to my webpage the
button appears as expected,
but nothing happens
when I press it.
I've seen quite a few
cases like this.
The Google Checkout button
is easily insertable in
any HTML web page.
It is a form HTML element.
And you just have to copy paste
the snippet we generate
for your on your page.
The reason that nothing happens,
even though you see
the button, suggests
that something is
wrong with the form.
Something is missing in the
form, it's not posting to the
correct website, or the form
is completely gone.
So the first thing I would do
is to run an HTML validator
and make sure that the form
looks as expected.
You can also have a look at the
site inside the debugger.
Use one of the Chrome debugging
web tools or Firebug
in Firefox.
And make sure that the form
appears the same as it was
when you copy pasted it.
The reason is that if you
inserted it in the wrong place
in the HTML, you break the--
let's say you were breaking the
nesting structure of HTML,
then the browsers may get
confused, and they would not
close the form correctly,
or remove the form tag
altogether.
And so the form is gone.
One example I've seen is someone
inserting the form
element inside a span tag.
So that will break it because
span is an inline element,
form is a block element, and you
cannot have block elements
inside inline elements.
And some different browsers will
react differently to this
type of situation.
Any other--
PENG YING: I mean, I've also
seen within certain HTML
editors-- so some sites, they
have their own HTML editors
built in as web HTML editors
instead of text made, or text
pad, or whatever.
And then within those, I've seen
that sometimes when you
click Save, it actually strips
the elements that it doesn't
want to allow.
So for example, if you paste a
form into Blogger, I believe
that Blogger will strip
out the form tags.
If you paste a form element into
Google Sites, I believe
Google Sites also strips
out the form tags.
So sometimes the HTML editors
can do this to you.
And then if you save it, and
then you go back to it and
you're like, hey, where did
the form tags go, that's a
good indication that something
is happening there.
The workarounds for those two
specific sites are using
something called gadgets.
So I believe within both Blogger
and on Google Sites,
you can add in gadgets to handle
the form post for you,
to handle the Buy Now button
action for you.
And the difference between
gadgets and regular forms is
that gadgets are always
I-framed, so then the security
is a little bit different.
MIHAI IONESCU: So, you
want to go on?
PENG YING: Ah, I take
the next one.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah,
take the next one.
PENG YING: OK, will Google
Wallet be integrated with
Google Shopper, and Google
Offers, et cetera.
And this one I can take from
a bunch of different ways.
This is pretty open ended.
So let's start with Google
Wallet and Google Offers.
I mean, to buy a Google Offer,
you already have to use Google
Wallet to purchase.
In terms of the future, I think
the question here is
talking about, can you
redeem offers with a
single tap of Wallet.
And then in this case, I
believe, if you look at the
previous history of what we've
done with loyalty cards about
passing all the information at
once with a single tap or with
a single purchase confirmation,
I think that's
the direction that we're going
to be headed in, of enabling
and simplifying transactions
where you pass a lot of
information at once.
And then you don't need to
pass anything additional
beyond that.
In terms of Google Shopper and
Google Wallet, I think the
question here is, will you be
able to purchase items from
Google Shopper using
Google Wallet.
And for that one, I
don't really know.
I think they're going
to probably do some
more research on it.
If there's some sort of market
benefit, if there's some sort
of benefit to merchants and
consumers for enabling
purchases in Google Shopper,
then we'll do it.
But other than that, I'm
not quite sure there.
MIHAI IONESCU: Come back and
ask the question in a few
months, maybe we'll know more.
All right, let me take
the next one.
The question is, will Google
Wallet be able to
be used with tablets.
So I assume you are referring
to NFC tablets.
And if the tablet has an NFC
chip, then obviously, you can
use Google Wallet.
As an example, the Nexus 7 has
an NFC chip and the Galaxy
Nexus 10 has two NFC chips.
So definitely you can use Wallet
with those tablets.
And keep in mind to use Google
Wallet tap and pay you do not
need a carrier or a wireless
connection.
You just turn on Wallet and you
can make the transaction.
PENG YING: I guess I'll
take the next one.
Will there be a scan slash
picture entering manual system
for non major credit card
slash reward cards.
That's a good question.
So there's a lot of cards.
And I think OCR of credit cards
and other things to
enter in those credentials is
something that would be really
useful for consumers.
It drastically simplifies that
flow because you take a
picture of a card and all
your details are in.
For non major credit cards and
rewards cards, I think that's
going to be a little bit more
of a challenge because it
won't be as automatic as having
the standard that
everybody uses.
We would have to create some
sort of OCR templates for each
specific card type and then be
able to recognize and scan
through that.
I'm not sure if it'll be done.
I want to say that we would
probably want to work with all
the partners to do this.
Maybe the partner creates a
template, and then just adds
it into our system.
And then we can just
automatically scan their cards
or something like that.
I want to say that, yes, I think
it's useful, but I don't
know if it'll actually
get built out.
MIHAI IONESCU: Who knows what
the future will be.
Maybe we'll have some QR codes
that encapsulate all this
information.
And then they will be--
PENG YING: Yeah, so universal.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, but I think
for today's world, it is
probably useful to have a
scanning app that scans your
driver's license, or your
library card, stuff like that.
Then you have them handy.
I know in California you can
now present your insurance
information on the phone.
If you have it in
digital format--
PENG YING: Just imagine
the IDs on the phone.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah,
IDs on the phone.
Everything would be good.
So it's not a Google Wallet
specific question, but it's
useful, in general, to have
this kind of app on a
smartphone.
I'll take the next question.
This one it's about the
digital goods API.
Question is, I implemented the
InApp payments API in the
sandbox using the App Engine
on the server side.
I can complete a transaction
without the postbackURL, but
when I add the postbackURL, I
don't get the call back and
the transaction fails.
So the great news is that it
works without a postbackURL.
You are 90% done.
You have very little
work left to do.
You created the JWT, the
transaction completes
correctly, Google does not
reject your payment
information, and you already
done some server work to
generate the JWT.
You know how to parse it,
encode it, decode it.
So it looks like, on the
programming side you know what
needs to be done.
Now the problem is, why
aren't you getting
back the call back?
So the first thing to check is
on the client side handler
check the error code return.
And I believe it should
be postback error.
That's what--
you're getting--
try--
the postback, it just did not
receive back the confirmation.
So somewhere along the
way something broke.
Check that you're not
behind a login wall.
In a lot of cases Google App
Engine, when you create an
account, it has restriction who
can post to your site, so
sometimes you are behind
a login wall.
And then the call
back gets lost.
So check your logs, see what's
happening there.
PENG YING: One easy way to
test is to actually curl
content to your postback
handler, or to your web
service handler.
So that way you can just do
something from terminal.
You type in curl, the data
you want to send
over, and the URL.
And that'll just post it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Right, so
simulate what Google
is doing in a way.
And make sure you can
handle that case.
And then, of course, there is
the 10 second delay issue.
Even though that's a pretty long
delay, who knows what may
happen on your server side.
Make sure, if you get
a call back, you
respond within 10 seconds.
And then the order
will go through.
Then you'll receive the correct
confirmation on the
client side and then the
transaction is complete.
So if you still can't figure it
out, then post a question
on Stack Overflow in the groups
and someone from our
team or the community will
jump in and help.
PENG YING: Cool, I'll
take the next one.
Can I charge credit cards via
server side only to Google
Wallet, e.g.
a HTTP post?
I don't want to use any client
side code to provide my own
web page and that does
all the charging.
It seems to me that you're
looking for more of a payment
gateway functionality, where you
can just pass over credit
card information and then charge
that amount and capture
the proceeds of the sale.
Currently, Google Wallet
doesn't offer any
solutions like this.
In this case, the purchases
always need to complete on
Google Wallet slash
Google Checkout.
However, we do offer
a new flow.
It's called Google Wallet
for Online Commerce.
The difference is that it's like
a OAuth 2 style access to
Google Payment Credentials.
So what we'll do is we'll
actually pass you over, you as
a merchant, a one time use
card that you can charge
against your payment gateway.
So that's something that's a
little bit different and maybe
more useful to you.
For just the payment gateway
aspect of it, you may be more
interested in a solution such
as authorize.net or Chase
Paymentech, that can perform
the API charge requests.
MIHAI IONESCU: Where can people
find out more about the
Online Commerce API?
PENG YING: You find out more
about the Online Commerce API
at developers.googl
e.com/commerce/wallet/online.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
do one more question.
I'll take it.
The question is, I have trouble
posting a digital
subscription order.
I get a purchased cancelled
failure code.
How do I debug this?
So purchase canceled indicates
that either the buyer
cancelled the transaction,
or something went
wrong with the order.
Either the payment failed or
there was some time out, some
expiration, and the order
is not valid anymore.
So I would, first, have
a look at the JWT.
You are correctly constructing
the JWT.
Google is not rejecting it,
but check the issued and
expiration times.
Those may not be
valid anymore.
And then Google thinks that
the order has expired.
And it simply returns
the error code.
Second, check your buyer
account, the sample buyer
account you're using
for this purchase.
Make sure the credit cards
look correctly.
They are the test cards
that we're offering.
And generally, that there's
nothing wrong
with the buyer account.
Try different credit cards--
we have at least four that you
can try with-- and see if that
fixes the problem.
If none of this works, then I
would go and try one of our
samples on the developer
sample code site
and then work backwards.
Do changes to that sample one
by one to match your changes
and see if it breaks.
That should fix it.
If it doesn't, again, the groups
and Stack Overflow are
a great resource.
PENG YING: Yeah, Stack Overflow
is a great resource.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
I think that
was it for this session.
So Happy New Year again.
And we'll see you soon,
in a couple of weeks.
PENG YING: Yup, see you
in a few weeks.